it is Narendra modi's hour of Triumph
elected for a second term as India's
prime minister the head of the Hindu
nationalist BJP party basked in the
adulation of the crowds
but in his victory speech Modi struck a
modest tone
I've always said that this election is
not fought by the majority it's not
fought by the hopefuls
it's not fought by politicians
this election is being fought by the
people of this country
[Applause]
voting in the world's largest democracy
took place over six weeks as incoming
election results showed that the
incumbent prime minister would remain in
office people gathered to cheer their
old and new leader
modi's Victory crushed hopes of a
political comeback by the Gandhi Dynasty
Rahul Gandhi head of the congress party
and modi's election rival conceded
defeat early on Thursday
clearly said during the campaign that
the people of India are the Mandate and
they have given an order so first of all
I would like to congratulate Narendra
Modi
congratulation also came in from another
rival Pakistan's prime minister Imran
Khan tweeted that he looked forward to
working with Modi for peace in South
Asia
the two countries came close to war when
pakistan-based militants staged a terror
attack and the disputed Kashmir region
critics had accused Modi of exploiting
those tensions to gain votes
but replying to Khan Modi also pledged a
desire for peace
the next five years will show if Modi
really does make good on his words
and we're going to be joined Now by tw's
nimisha jaiswal in Delhi so nimisha this
was a resounding win for the governing
BJP it seems polls were expecting it to
fall short of an overall majority was
this election about the issues or was it
about Narendra Modi
well definitely a resounding win one
that was actually bigger than the one
they had in 2014 which was historic in
itself so clearly the Mandate has
completely supported Narendra Modi and
when you ask about what's what was the
selection about Narendra Modi I think
it's pretty safe to say yes over the
course of this election it was seen as a
referendum on the Prime Minister and the
last five years office tenure and when
you actually look at the campaigning
that the BJP has done it has centered
around the Prime Minister and around
rising up National Security sentiment
there was a standoff between India and
Pakistan earlier this year and a
decisive action by the Prime Minister
What was seen as a decisive action
actually shored up his support
significantly the opposition raised
issues of the highest unemployment in 45
years the farmer crisis a possible
corruption within governance but none of
these issues seem to have stuck or
damaged the prime minister at all he's
coming back with an even larger mandate
and on the flip side it was also a
stunning defeat for the opposition
congress party Rahul Gandhi lost the
longtime family seat in uttar Pradesh is
this the beginning of the end for the
Gandhi Dynasty
well that question has been raised
before but it has never been as relevant
as it is right now the Indian National
Congress was only marginally able to
raise its seat count when compared to
2014 they went out they went all out on
the campaign raising the issues that I
just mentioned they even put out a
strong Manifesto but none of these
messages seemed to have appealed to the
waters and that question is being raised
repeatedly by political uh by by
analysts as well as people in the media
that is a time for the president of the
Indian National Congress Rahul Gandhi to
reconsider to perhaps even step down and
for the Congress itself to think about
its relevance given that even with five
years even with the potential two raila
Banta incumbency sentiment they have
pretty much entirely failed it's also
worth noting that Regional parties that
was also expected to play an important
role have also not done well in this
election they've actually done worse
than they did back in 2014 so a complete
route of the opposite position by the
ruling BJP
so Modi had as we said a decisive
Victory but he's got a lot of challenges
facing him for his next term what do you
think is going to be top of his agenda
well I'm afraid there are actually no
challenges to the Prime Minister
Narendra Modi government I did mention
Pharma distress I did mention higher
unemployment the the economy has been
floundering in different ways but none
of this seems to matter because the
Mandate that he has been awarded seems
to say that the last five years have
actually been great let's get more of
that so while of course these are issues
a government has to address he has
talked about leading an inclusive
government leading a government that
that rises above cost politics and
religion politics it we will have to
wait and watch what exactly this
government chooses to focus on will they
address the issues that have been raised
when they are being criticized or will
they just take this mandate to plow on
ahead with just about a free hand in
whatever they wish to do they have
almost a two-thirds majority in in
Parliament including their Coalition so
of course a very strong hand and we'll
just have to wait and watch exactly how
they select how they choose to exercise
this Faith this trust mandate that they
have been awarded DW correspondent
nimisha jaiswal in Delhi for us thank
you so much